willkommen zu bild live und einen
schönen guten morgen haben diesen
mittwoch an dem das chaos an den
flughäfen vermutlich seinen traurigen
höhepunkt erreicht denn die lufthansa
hat für heute fast alle flüge an den
drehkreuzen frankfurt und münchen
gestrichen weil die gewerkschaft verdi
die rund 20.000 beschäftigten des
lufthansa bodenpersonal zum streik
aufgerufen hat 130 tausend passagiere
werden deshalb heute nicht in den urlaub
fliegen können ja und soeben gab es ein
statement der lufthansa heavy rain was
der pressesprecher martin leutke gesagt
hat
dass heute nicht trauriger tag für alle
menschen die reisen wollten die lange
urlaub geplant haben die auf urlaub
gewartet haben diese urlaubsträume
wurden leider durch den streik zum
großteil zumindest mal verschoben
vielleicht sogar zerstört dieser streik
ist völlig unnötig er ist auch völlig
überzogen wir sind im gespräch mit der
bm zwei gesprächsrunden eine weitere ist
vereinbart für die kommende woche ein
ausmaß das war jetzt heute erleben das
ist überzogen und im sinne der kunden
vor allen dingen unsere gäste nicht
nachvollziehbar wir haben ein sehr gutes
angebot gemacht das genau reflektiert
dass die preise steigen und deshalb
haben wir in den niedrigen
gehaltsklassen bis zu 15 prozent
lohnplus angeboten bei dem mittleren
gehaltsklassen zehn prozent in den
höheren gehaltsklassen ungefähr 6% dass
gleich die inflation aus und das ist ein
angebot mit dem man hätte weiter reden
können in der nächsten woche sind
verhandlungstermine vereinbart dass man
jetzt heute einen solchen massiven
streik macht auf dem rücken der
reisenden ist nicht nachvollziehbar ja
unser absolut größtes ziel ist es dass
nach dem streik sprich ab morgen früh
der flugverkehr wieder normal
stattfindet wir haben ein sehr reise
starkes wochenende vor uns die ferien
beginnen in bayern die ferien beginnen
baden württemberg und unser großes ziel
ist es dass am kommenden wochenende der
flugbetrieb ganz normal stattfinden kann
möglicherweise kann es zu einzelnen
ausfällen noch kommen aber ich gehe
davon aus dass der flugbetrieb dann nach
dem streik wieder normal an läuft ja wir
haben alle betroffenen passagiere
gestern informiert nachdem die flüge
dann aus dem system genommen worden sind
wir versuchen die passagiere umzubuchen
so gut das eben geht um den passagieren
alternative reisemöglichkeiten zu bieten
wir sind im austausch mit den gründen so
gut es eben geht und empfehlen heute an
dem streiktag gar nicht erst einen
flughafen zu kommen weil im prinzip
digital wir besser helfen können im
moment als sie am flughafen
ja was macht derweil der der für diesen
streik verantwortlich ist verdi chef
frank werneke halten sie sich fest der
ist im urlaub bis zum zwölfter august
wohin er verreist es das wollte man uns
aber nichts
und wie reagiert die gewerkschaft verdi
auf twitter
und der versaut gerade richtig vielen
menschen in deutschland die ferien
dürfen wir vorstellen
frank werneke seines zeichens verdi chef
und seine gewerkschaft hatten jetzt zum
warnstreik bei der lufthansa aufgerufen
knapp 20.000 beschäftigte des
bodenpersonals auch euro wings und
andere tochter fluggesellschaften liegen
ab mittwochfrüh bis donnerstagmorgen um
6 uhr die arbeit nieder ausgerechnet
jetzt wo seit wochen an deutschen
flughäfen das reinste chaos herrscht und
so gut wie gar nichts mehr geht das
erhoffte ziel stillstand noch mehr chaos
und das mitten in der urlaubszeit die
traurige konsequenz für viele urlauber
bedeutet dies dass der geplante urlaub
schlicht nicht stattfinden wird die
airline streich kurzerhand knapp 1000
flüge ersatzlos ein fiasko für das image
des weltkonzerns auf seiten der
gewerkschaften hält man trotzdem an der
gewählten linie fest so gibt wernickes
vize christian behle zu verstehen ein
streik im flugverkehr trifft leider
immer die passagiere für ihre
verärgerung haben wir vollstes
verständnis die belastungen sind aber
für die beschäftigten zur zeit kaum
auszuhalten kaum auszuhalten ist auch
die unverfrorenheit mit der unschuldige
urlauber von seiner gewerkschaft in
geiselhaft genommen werden von
warnstreiks kann man hier nicht mehr
sprechen zwangs streik passt da wohl
eher was da wohl ihr chef der fand dazu
sagt wüssten wir auch gern doch auf
unsere anfragen reagiert er nicht wo ist
der gewerkschaftsboss sie werden es
nicht glauben im urlaub während wir
nicht weg kommen hat sich der fiese
frank in die ferien verabschiedet kommt
am 12 8 wieder und genießt die sonne
versaut tausenden deutschen bürgern die
ferienzeit und hinterlässt reisechaos
und geplatzte urlaubsträume wie
wernickes urlaubsgruß wohl bei den
deutschen reisenden an den deutschen
flughäfen ankommt macht keinen spaß die
sollen irgendwann alles streiken aber
nicht wenn mal in urlaub fliegen wollen
gerade zur ferienzeit viele freuen sich
auf den urlaub und gerade familien mit
kindern wir haben ferienzeit ich denke
das hätte man durchaus auch nach den
ferien ja auch so ist es mit meinem
leben nicht also die ganz oben
genießen das manchmal wie ihrer art und
na ja der kleine kann nur zugucken
der unmut der betroffenen fluggäste mehr
als nachvollziehbar der fiese frank haut
ab in den urlaub und versaut und die
ferien
und wie reagierte die gewerkschaft verdi
auf twitter sie startet mit hohn und
spott gegen die deutsche lufthansa in
diesem tag sie schreibt nach zwei tagen
social media turbulenz monte erkenntnis
dass tarifpolitik kaum einen kalt lässt
gehen unsere solidarischen grüße nicht
nur an die kollegen bei der lufthansa
sondern an alle die sich für ihre
beschäftigten interessen stark machen
und sich engagieren und wir wollen
natürlich jetzt wissen wie ist die lage
in diesem moment an den flughäfen in
deutschland und deshalb schalten wir
jetzt nach frankfurt münchen und nach
düsseldorf zu unseren reportern jessica
verleih in frankfurt benedikt weimar in
münchen und michael engelberg in
düsseldorf hallo an euch dreien da
draußen erst mal zu jessica nach
frankfurt jessica frankfurt schwer
gebeutelt von diesem streik wie ist die
momentane lage jetzt
ich muss sagen es wird immer vielleicht
mal selbst ein bisschen überrascht weil
ja ausdrücklich gesagt wurde zu hause
bleiben digital kann man für jeden mehr
machen als hier vor ort ist versuchen
trotzdem glaube ich immer mehr leute
sich hier an zu stellen und vielleicht
den flug doch noch umzubuchen doch noch
in urlaub zu können aber grundsätzlich
natürlich auch viele hier die irgendwie
aus den usa kommen und weiter wolle nach
kopenhagen und deshalb hier in
zwischenstopp einlegen und einfach
warten und schauen wie es weitergeht die
meisten wissen es nämlich noch nicht es
wurden so viele flüge gestrichen auch
hier bei mir an dieser tafel es ist
unglaublich habe mal drauf geschaut auf
vorher nochmal da steht überall
cancelled cancelled cancelled cancelled
suchen die kleine snack bar aufgebaut
hier rechts neben mir da kann man sich
zu bedienen da waren wirklich gar nicht
mehr weiß wie es weitergeht aber es wird
auf jeden fall immer voller und immer
chaotischer jessica du hast die
ausländischen touristen angesprochen die
jetzt in deutschland schon sind und mit
der lufthansa weiterreisen wollen wurden
die im vorfeld informiert
also es wurden alle informierte soweit
ich jetzt weiß und mit denen ich
gesprochen habt ihr war jetzt nicht so
dass er sich total überrascht waren wir
nicht wussten wohin der kopf steht sie
wurden alle informiert die meisten von
den bayern eigentlich auch ziemlich
entspannt und haben es einfach
hingenommen weil sie sagen sie können ja
nicht der situation ändern es ist wie es
ist und müssen jetzt einfach warten
ausharren geduldig bleiben und hoffen
natürlich auch auf entschädigung besten
dank jessica für diesen moment nach
frankfurt gehen wir weiter nach münchen
zu benedikt weimar venedig wie ist die
situation in münchen wie viele
passagiere kommt tatsächlich zum
flughafen und stehen dann da und können
nicht weg
ja auch hier sehen wir dass die schlange
immer länger wird wir haben auf der
einen seite den check in schalter der
ist weiterhin leer die meisten
passagiere wussten bescheid und sind gar
nicht erst zum flughafen gekommen es
gibt einige die da hinten jetzt am
serviceschalter warten da wird die
schlange gerade immer länger wir sind ja
schon seit dem frühen morgen da und
viele versuchen jetzt innerhalb
deutschlands ihren flug umzubuchen das
sind dann passagiere die nach leipzig
nach düsseldorf nach berlin fliegen
wollten von münchen aus und viele von
denen werden jetzt mit dem zug weiter
geleitet kommen dann später an aber wir
haben auch mit leuten gesprochen die
wussten gar nicht dass dieser streik
stattfindet wir haben mit einem
gesprochen aus frankreich der wollte
nach toulouse fliegen mit dem habe ich
gesprochen da sagte er er total
überrascht er wusste gar nicht dass der
flug nicht fliegt und steht jetzt hier
ziemlich verzweifelt im zimmerservice
schlange oder ein pärchen aus boston ein
trauriges schicksal das jetzt nicht
zusammen nach boston fliegen kann
sondern wo der mann heute fliegt und die
frau kann erst in einer woche fliegen
das heißt die sind jetzt eine woche lang
auseinander die frau ist hier stecken
geblieben in münchen muss hier ins hotel
und die hoffen natürlich alle dass die
lufthansa das hotel zahlt im besten fall
und sich so schnell wie möglich dann in
die heimat können ärgerlich für die
passagiere vielen dank venedig weimar in
münchen und jetzt möchten wir natürlich
noch mit michael engelberg sprechen in
düsseldorf am düsseldorfer flughafen
michael wie ist die lage dort vor ort in
düsseldorf
guten morgen aus düsseldorf also die
lage ist ja schon hier in düsseldorf am
airport seit beginn der sommerferien
extremst angespannt bewahrte schlangen
bis auf den parkplatz bis zum parkhaus
quasi weil hier natürlich auch das
personal fehlt ich gehe mal ein bisschen
zur seite wir stehen hier am lufthansa
check-in und man sieht da sind zwei sehr
sehr freundliche personen die noch für
austrian airlines leute einchecken und
die natürlich nichts sagen dürfen weil
ja die vielleicht einen maulkorb
bekommen haben und hier versuchen noch
etwas angesäuerte leute irgendwie
umzubuchen wir haben mit vielen leuten
schon gesprochen ein mann der zum
beispiel auf zypern wohnt der immer alle
14 tage nach deutschland kommt hier nach
düsseldorf um sie hier medizinisch
behandeln zu lassen er sagt er hätte
gestern schon den ganzen tag hier am
flughafen verbracht um sich umbuchen zu
lassen und der war wirklich sehr sehr
sauer hat dann hier extra noch
übernachten müssen im hotel hat nichts
zu essen bekommen und versucht dann
jetzt heute im laufe des tages zu
fliegen wir haben aber auch schon mit
einem
generalsekretär der gewerkschaft
gesprochen und der sagt das problem sei
hier in düsseldorf das tochterfirmen zum
beispiel
auf den rollfeldern aktiv sind das heißt
für den so genannten push back flugzeuge
starten normalerweise
rückwärts werden rausgeschoben aus der
parkposition und können dann den
vorwärtsgang ein leben jetzt hat man das
schlauerweise so gemacht dass man
versucht die flieger rückwärts
einzuparken damit sie vorwärts raus
fahren weil natürlich diese push back
dienste nicht erfolgreich funktioniert
das heißt kein personal kein putsch
becker und dann ja dann wird es
schwierig aber die airlines haben sich
wohl darauf verständigt dass man
irgendwo noch personal akquiriert die
dann diesen push back durchführen sagt
aber auch der herr von verdi ja sehr ein
bisschen kritisch weil das sind ja
tatsächlich fachleute ich das machen und
das kann man tatsächlich nicht
bewerkstelligen wenn man in der vierten
klasse die fahrradprüfung gestanden hat
also da muss tatsächlich schon ein
bisschen was passieren er geht
allerdings auch davon aus dass sich das
hier am düsseldorfer flughafen im
weiteren verlauf des nachmittags zu
weiteren ausfällen kommen wird weil dann
nämlich eventuell die flieger irgendwo
auf dem rollfeld stehen nicht mehr in
der ordentlichen parkposition das ist
natürlich auch schwierig ist diese
flieger bereitzustellen und viele mit
denen wir gesprochen haben viele
passagiere die sind tatsächlich
angefressen obwohl ganz wichtig sie
können auch verstehen dass das personal
streik grund ist nämlich in der korona
zeit sind ganz ganz viele leute
freigesetzt worden ganz viele haben sich
auch andere jobs gesucht dass es
irgendwann zurück kommt und dass man
weiter arbeiten muss und dass die leute
wieder fliegen wollen in den urlaub so
wie wir alle war irgendwie abzusehen
das hat nicht so richtig funktioniert da
ist das personal irgendwie ausgeblieben
inflation ist nicht nur hier am
flughafen thema haben wir alle mit zu
kämpfen und deshalb fordern sie
vernünftige löhne und dann ist es
natürlich auch klar dass man sich einen
tag in den ferien aussucht es ist hohe
nachfrage hohe hohes verkehrsaufkommen
und es bringt den leuten nichts wenn
keiner fliegt und deshalb wird gestreikt
besten dank an euch dreien sie hat uns
den ganzen tag über auf dem laufenden
und den flughäfen deutschlands
[Musik]